AND ANTHONY SCARAMUCCI MAY BE
BACK AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
HAPPY NEW YEAR.
TIME.
>> Laura: LET'S TALK ABOUT YOU
AND THE WHITE HOUSE.
I'M READING THESE STORIES ADD
REPORTS THAT, YOU TALK TO THE
PRESIDENT REGULARLY, HE HAS AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF RESPECT AND
AFFECTION FOR YOU.
THERE'S SOME DESIRE TO BRING YOU
BACK IN.
>> THAT'S ALL NEWS TO ME.
I ADDRESSED THAT ON HOW WE
SHOULD SHOW OVER THE WEEKEND.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF NONSENSE.
I'M NOT A PRESUMPTUOUS PERSON.
I DON'T EXPECT TO GO BACK TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
I CERTAINLY SET ON THE YEAR I
GREAT JOB.
I THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY,
I THOUGHT TODAY'S COMMUNICATION
STRATEGY WAS ABSOLUTELY
BRILLIANT, MY HATS OFF TO THEM
FOR ALLOWING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TO SEE THE PRESIDENT THE WAY YOU
DOES THE PRESIDENT, AND HIS
EXTREME PRESIDENTIAL NATURE
WHICH YOU SAW TODAY FOR
45 MINUTES.
>> Laura: DON'T YOU LOVE HOW
THE LEFT KEEP SAYING HOW HE IS
MENTALLY UNSTABLE?
THEY ARE SO DESPERATE TO TRY TO
DISCOUNT HIS SUCCESSES AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
WHAT'S FUNNY ABOUT THIS IS THEY
ARE THE ONES BECOMING MORE AND
MORE UNHINGED DISTURBED ALMOST.
>> I DON'T WANT TO GIVE THEM A
LOT OF ADVICE ON YOUR WELL RATED
SHOW BECAUSE I KNOW THEY ARE
LISTENING.
THE ADVICE I WOULD GIVE THEM IS
YOU SHOULD STOP THAT'S BECAUSE
YOU ARE PLAYING RIGHT INTO HIS
HANDS.
HE WANTS YOU TO GO OFF THE
RAILS.
HE WANTS YOU TO GO CRAZY ON HIM
EVERY SINGLE DAY AND NIGHT
BECAUSE YOU LOOK SO DISINGENUOUS
AND YOU LOOK SO EMOTIONALLY
INVOLVED IN IT TO THE POINT
WHERE YOU'VE LOST YOUR
OBJECTIVITY COMPLETELY.
THE PRESIDENT STOKING THAT,
DESCRIBING HIMSELF AS A STABLE
GENIUS, I THOUGHT THAT WAS
TERRIFIC.
I ADDED THAT TO MY VERNACULAR
THE DAY, HE'S DOING A GREAT JOB.
YOU KNOW IT, I KNOW HE'S DOING A
GREAT JOB.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS TONIGHT
ARE GOING BACK TO THEIR
BOARDROOMS OR WHEREVER THEY GO
AND LOOK AT EACH OTHER AND HE
LOOKS UNBELIEVABLY PRESIDENTIAL.
>> Laura: HE SAID SOMETHING
WELL, HE IS A GLOBALIST BY
NATURE.
HE WANTS TO BE PART OF THE WORLD
ORDER.
>> Laura: IT GLOBALIST BY
NATURE, PART OF THE WORLD ORDER.
THE U.N., LET'S LOOK.
>> President Trump: BOTH OUR
FRIENDS AND OUR ENEMIES PUT
THEIR COUNTRIES ABOVE OURS.
WE WHILE BEING FAIR TO THEM MUST
COUNTRY OR ITS PEOPLE TO THE
FALSE SONG OF GLOBALISM.
>> Laura: HE SAID HE'S AGAINST
THIS GLOBALIST APPROACH FOR
AMERICAN SOVEREIGNTY.
>> I GOT CUT OFF A LITTLE BIT
OVER THERE SO LET ME FINISH IT
OVER HERE.
WHAT I WAS TRYING TO SAY IS
THERE IS A DUALITY TO THE
HIS PERSONALITY WHERE HE WANTS
TO BE PART OF THE WORLD ORDER,
HE'S GOING TO DOUBLE'S IN TWO
WEEKS.
HE RECOGNIZES THE INTERNATIONAL
AT THE SAME TIME, SUPERSEDING
ALL OF THAT IS HIS AMERICA FIRST
STRATEGY, TAKING CARE OF THE
PERSONALITY.
I WAS TRYING TO GET THAT OUT
OVER THERE.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME GET IT
OUT OVER HERE.
HE DOES WANT TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE GLOBAL COMMUNITY.
>> Laura: HE'S NOT NOT AN
ISOLATIONIST.
MY POINT IS HE HAS SPECIFICALLY
CAMPAIGNED AGAINST THE
PHILOSOPHY OF GLOBALISM.
IT IS A PHILOSOPHY THAT ERASES
TO A GLOBAL ORDER.
WHEN I HEAR GLOBAL ORDER, I HEAR
WHAT YOUR FREEDOM, WATCH YOUR
INDEPENDENCE.
>> ITS VERNACULAR, THEY TWISTED
THAT BARBED WIRE.
WHEN I TALK ABOUT THE GLOBAL
ORDER I TALK ABOUT OUR ALLIES,
THE STRENGTH OF OUR ALLIES, HAND
CHECKING OUR ADVERSARIES.
>> Laura: THAT'S NOT OBAMA'S
GLOBALISM.